[Music]
a georgia sheriff is reopening the
investigation
into the mysterious death of a teenager
more than eight years ago
surveillance video shows kendrick
johnson less than 24 hours
before he died in january 2013
his body was later found inside a rolled
up gin mat at his valdosta high school
investigators quickly ruled it an
accident but his parents
have never believed that mark strossman
spoke to johnson's family about what
they hope to learn
we want to warn you some of the details
are disturbing
we want to know what happened to
kendrick johnson
why nothing has been done and why nobody
has been held accountable
jacqueline johnson wants justice for her
youngest son
you feel that loss every day every day
every second of the hours
in january of 2013 surveillance video
showed kendrick johnson
walking the hallways at his high school
sometime in the next 24 hours
the 17 year old three sport athlete died
his body found the next day rolled up
head first
in this wrestling mat kendrick was in
one of the place
that should have been the safest place
for him to be at
anyone don't know corner kendra was at
school trying to get his education
state investigators rule to death an
accident
they initially said johnson dove into
the mat to retrieve a shoe
got stuck and died from positional
asphyxia
but two other autopsies requested by the
family
in the following months determined blunt
force trauma to the neck
caused his death i know that my son was
beat to death
and rolled up in the mat i'm not going
to even say think again i
know my song was beat to death no way in
your mind it was an accident
no no way a federal civil rights
investigation followed
but in 2016 the department of justice
determined
it lacked evidence to file hate crime
charges as it would have needed to prove
he was killed because of his race that
investigation's results were sealed
but now for the first time investigators
will have access to that evidence
coupled with the state's original files
lowndes county sheriff ashley park
was not part of the original
investigation but will lead the new one
i made him a promise i made the people
this county i promise
i'm pretty well known for keeping my
promises marcus coleman
is the johnson family spokesman now that
this investigation has been reopened in
the sheriff's department
we feel like those array of charges that
literally fit what happened to kendrick
can now be applied
what do you think those charges will be
murder oh we'll be
we're hoping sir we're cautiously
optimistic
uh that murder will be hit uh dealt down
here
a fresh look that could mean different
answers for this family
for cbs this morning i'm mark strassman
thank you mark strassman i remember that
story very well and it never made any
sense to me
how could you be accidentally rolled up
in a mat that happy number one
takes a whole bunch of people to roll
them makes no sense i'm glad the
family's pursuing it because
your heart goes out to us absolutely and
there's either blunt force trauma there
or there is
not you know and i'm glad somebody's
taking another look